Ad Slogans.
How many times have you been in your car with your radio on, gotten out, and hours later,...
...had some jingle playing in your head?
This, is good advertising.
That jingle was so catchy that hours after you had been exposed to it, it still lingered.
You might find yourself humming the tune,...
...and people might say, "Sorry?"...
...or "Did you say something?"
...the same can be said of ad slogans.
Every day, we are surrounded by car ads, credit card ads, travel ads, food ads, clothing ads,...
...the list goes on.
The purpose of the slogan in an advertisement...
...is to leave the key brand message in the mind of the target.
That's us.
Its goal is to stick:...
"If you get nothing else from this ad, get this...!"
We don't find ourselves asking "I'm sorry could you be more specific about the product?"...
...or "Could you tell me about this in more detail?"
No! We just want whatever was shown to us in the ad!
In the United States, omitting words such as 'the' and 'and',...
...the five most frequently used words in slogans are 'you' (11.15%),...
...'your' (7.94%),...
...'we' (6.03%),...
...'world' (4.18%)...
...and 'best' (2.67%), according to AD Slogans.